[Musique]
je suis chucky veux jouer
c'est le 31 octobre
hackensack est un refuge pour les bizarres
les fous et les
criminels complètement fous
historiquement parlant la violence dans
notre belle ville a toujours augmenté à
Halloween où
as-tu eu ça
je n'ai aucune idée 20 dollars pas juste
cette poupée effrayante me fait juste
flipper moi aussi
salut
je
suis chucky bonjour ouais je t'appelle à propos de la
poupée quoi
sois très prudent avec cette poupée de quoi
tu parles
as-tu vérifié son  batteries
[Musique]
il y a cette légende urbaine à propos de charles
lee redd
il était un tueur en série décédé dans les
années 80 il a terrorisé chicago pendant des années
prolifiques
avant de mourir il a transféré son âme
dans un bon gars poupée
salut
je suis chuckie
veux
jouer c'était ton  transfert d'âme vaudou standard
chucky nous a tous mis en pièces
la dernière pièce n'est pas entrée dans une poupée
bonjour chucky
longtemps
sans voir
aujourd'hui est mon jour de chance
charles lee ray est né à hackensack
il est de retour dans sa ville natale en mission
nous avons de grands projets  pour cet endroit
c'est tuer ou être tué
personne ne sait ce qui se passe
je suis trop vieux pour cette merde